now it's recall election day in
california time for voters to decide if
governor gasm gavin newsom will keep his
job president biden joined newsome last
night at the final rally before this
high-stakes election that could have
national consequences major garrett is
in marina del rey california where
democrats are confident they will win
major good morning
good morning nate good morning everyone
you know top advisors to governor newsom
told us something interesting last night
they said there is no scenario their
words no scenario in which the governor
loses this recall election that they
said was based on public polls their own
internal polls and what they described
as heavy early democratic turnout that
confidence notwithstanding here is what
we know eight million ballots have
already been sent in in this recall
election california spent more than 200
million dollars to hold it
and gavin newsom the governor has plowed
more than 65 million dollars into the
effort to keep his job
california
you've got to keep gavin newsom as
governor
in long beach last night president biden
and governor gavin newsom now aligned on
vaccine mandate said the recall is in
part a referendum on science and public
health voting no we'll be protecting
california from trump republicans trying
to block us from beating this pandemic
economic justice is on the ballot
tomorrow night
social justice is on the ballot tomorrow
night
today voters will decide on two
questions should newsome be recalled and
who among 46 candidates should replace
him
[Applause]
republican frontrunner and radio talk
show host larry elder has vowed to
reverse newsome's covid policies men and
women who did just that lost their
businesses because of the way gavin
newsom shut down the state while by the
way leaving his own winery open even so
recent polls show a majority of
california voters back those policies
meaning the issue that first jeopardized
newsom may save him i think he's doing
great for the environment i think he's
doing great for california california is
a deeply blue state but five weeks ago
democrats admit the race was close and
newsom in real trouble why recall him
now as opposed to waiting next year
until the regular general election i
mean it's just a year away
to get to get the guy out of there he's
not doing a job obviously
so let's
take a stand as americans and get them
out
for the governor to lose this election
the polls would not just have to be
wrong but spectacularly wrong that is
possible though not probable but if that
is what plays out here in california
californians won't know the result of
this recall election tonight wednesday
possibly not even until thursday but if
newsom prevails it will be possibly an
indicator to democrats nationwide about
enthusiasm heading toward the midterm
elections when of course the fate of
congress that is to say the control of
it and the biden agenda will be up for
debate and up for grabs gail
yep a lot of a lot at stake here thank
you major